hi today I'd like to talk about state
machines state machines are incredibly
important concept both in 601 and in the
general sense when you're going to be
doing things like control theory or
artificial intelligence or any any
further work you do in terms of
computability theory the state machines
are really important so I'm going to
review what we've done so far and talk
about why we now need state machines to
add additional complexity to the kinds
of models that we're going to build and
then talk a little bit about how state
machines are represented in different
domains and then also talk about how
we're going to use state machines in the
601 software first of all let's review
what we've learned so far
we've talked so far about functional
imperative and object-oriented
programming paradigms in functional
programming everything is function and
imperative programming we're allowed to
use functions but they're also allowed
to have side effects and in
object-oriented programming everything
is an object we can actually use the
first two to implement the last one and
use the first one plus you know an idea
of maintaining assignments to variables
that sort of thing to implement this one
so we've you can sort of trace the
progression of different kinds of
computer science languages along this
paradigm but the one thing that none of
these languages on their own allow us to
do is keep a notion of internal state
and what I mean by that is that if we
have a system that we want to model in
terms of the passage of time or keep
track of the evolution of that system or
keep track of some of the data that has
accumulated that has accumulated over
time in that system then we certainly
can't do it with functional programming
right functional programming takes one
input generates one output and you could
generate a function that you could
generate a list of code that took in
every possible you know concept you know
every possible situation and then
generated the logical output but that
would be a lot of code same thing for
imperative and object-oriented
programming them alone do not address
everything that we want to address which
is the ability to look at everything
that has happened as a
I went to the passage of time and all of
the data that we've looked at as a
consequence of the passage of time
synthesize it in some way and then
generate either you know whatever
whatever is supposed to come out of that
situation that is the notion of internal
state
state machines have been around for a
while you might see them referred to as
discrete finite automata there are also
such things as continuous state machines
but we're not going to talk about those
in this course so much so we're only
talking about discrete state machines
and when you see them referred to as
state machines or discrete finite
automata in literature especially in
mathematics you'll be looking for this
five set of things one is a set of the
possible states you could be in given a
particular state machine one is the set
of inputs you could possibly encounter
while in that state machine one is the
set of outputs that that state machine
could possibly generate one is a
transition function that looks at pairs
of these values and tells you based on
which state you're currently in what
state you will end up in as a
consequence of the current input and
then also specify what the output will
be as a consequence of that transition
and finally it'll tell you where you
start out that's a lot to absorb I'm
going to show you a state transition
diagram which many of you have probably
seen before and map these values to the
state state transition diagram in hopes
of making this a little bit more
concrete hopefully at this point all of
you have interacted with an MBTA
turnstile this is the thing that opens
and closes you know stick your RFID card
on it and then Richard Stallman yells at
you and possibly hands you more charlie
tickets or something like that it has
four states one of them is that this
turnstile could be closed and it's
waiting for people to interact with it
in some way it could be open and what I
you know anthropomorphize the turnstile
is being happy as a consequence of you
putting money in it it could be open and
quiet as a consequence of usually some
sort of other previous interaction with
another person or it could be open and
angry as a consequence of people
interacting with it when they should not
the vertices in this directed graph are
my set of states so when you see
something like this and you're asked to
map it to the mathematical construct
just grab the names and say this is my
set of states let's say I start off
enclosed and actually it occurs to me
that the other thing that should be
specified as a start state it's not here
so let's say the turnstile starts off as
clues usually this is an arrow coming
out of nowhere that directs into one of
the states sometimes it will be
explicitly indicated by saying start
state but typically you'll just see an
arrow
you know from network at this point I
don't have any inputs or outputs if I
put money in the turnstile it
constitutes input to my system it's
going to end up in my set of inputs for
math my transition function looks at the
state I'm in and looks at the current
input and generates the output and the
next state so all of these arrows in
addition to whatever information is
contained in the receiving vertex
specifies my transition function any
transition that's not specified is not
considered in the function right this
was not part of our original drawing so
if I was fed open angry there would be
no way to get to open happy likewise if
I was in open angry and fed money for
this simple system we're going to say
nothing would happen
I think at this point it's become clear
what you how to transform a state
transition diagram into the mathematical
constructs it's good to have the
mathematical constructs because they end
up being used in software which we'll
talk about in a second the first thing
I'm going to do is just walk around the
state transition diagram and indicate
what would be inputs what would be
outputs that sort of thing so let's say
I walk up to the turnstile
and somebody else interact with the
turnstile by exiting in this case exit
is the input none as the output the
turnstile doesn't make any noise and the
turnstile is open if at that point I
interact with the turnstile by entering
it's gonna make noise which is the
output and then the new state is going
to be the turnstile is open and angry at
that point you and I know that the
turnstile is going to close so this edge
indicates that the input that the only
available input at that point is to do
nothing or independent of anything else
it's going to suaq again and close one
more time
here the state's inputs are the first of
these two pairs outputs as a consequence
of the transition is a second of these
two pairs and the transition function is
represented by the directed edge and the
new state once you have all those sets
figured out you can start talking about
how to implement state machines and
software we've actually abstract AddThis
away for you from you you don't have to
deal with it but as a consequence you
should know how to interact with the
6:01 library let's look at an example of
the state machine class i want to build
an accumulator which at every time step
will look at the input add it to every
other example of input and output and
then output the new value and retain it
as the new state the first thing I need
to do is initialize the accumulator with
the value this is our start state which
is the same as our start state from the
MBTA's turnstile and also the same as
our start state from you know the
mathematical construct I also want
something called getnextvalues which is
the functional equivalent of the
transitions here's our self again for
moderate or any programming but we don't
care about that
we're going to look at the current state
and the current input
some getnextvalues will do some internal
data munging great possibly a
multiplication by two or you know
comparing to the previous input and then
having some conditionals that sort of
thing but there'll be some sort of very
simple function under getnextvalues at
least for the first couple weeks and
then we will return the new state and
the output in a tuple in this case the
new state is going to be the linear
combination of the current state and the
current input and the output is going to
be the linear combination of the current
state and the current input if I were to
draw this accumulator as a state
transition diagram I would do this
I start state as the initial value if I
pass it in a new input we'll call it
input zero both my output and the new
state
are gonna be the linear combination of
these two values if I made another
transition I would take whatever my next
input was and add it to the current
state value and return it out as the
output and so on and so forth
I encourage you to try this in Python or
I guess an idle and you know lunge
around with it and see what you can get
it to do you might have to type ad ad
lib 601 in order to get the state
machine class or initialize using
lipstick so one in order to get the
state machine class but otherwise this
should be enough to get you started with
the introduction to state machines
if you're having trouble I highly
recommend going through all the examples
in the readings they're pretty
comprehensive and it also includes the
accumulator that's all for now next time
we'll talk about linear time-invariant
systems